Це перша ракета, яка вдарила по Миколаївському зоопарку.
Це відбулося 28 лютого, на четвертий день війни.
Згодом - протягом шести місяців - у Миколаївський зоопарк прилетить
ще сім російських ракет. Дивом ніхто не постраждає:
ані працівники, ані тварини, які стали заручниками війни Росії проти України.
Тепер ці ракети - експонати.
Ми вирішили їх зберегти як нагадування про цю війну,
щоб наші нащадки теж відчували те, що відчували ми, коли жили в цей час.
Страшно було кожному, згадує директор зоопарку.
Утім, усі працівники продовжували працювати й навіть переїхали жити на роботу.
Колектив вирішив попри все зберегти найбільшу колекцію тварин в Україні.
А це близько чотири тисячі екземплярів.
Попри обстріли тварини потребували догляду та уваги.
Люди боялися. Приходили, кажуть: "Володимир Миколайович, мені страшно".
Я кажу: "Так мені ж теж страшно. Треба ж працювати. Нікуди ж ми не побіжимо".
Ми залишилися в зоопарку з нашими тваринами, тому що тварин
кудись повезти ми не могли. Коли була зима, морози,
слонів, жирафів, бегемотів, велику колекцію плазунів, риби, мавпи.
Куди везти і на чому везти? І в нас була одна дорога тільки на Одесу.
Все було перекрито, ми були вже в напівкільці.
Майже одразу почалися проблеми з кормом.
Його постачали з Херсонщини, яка на той момент була в окупації.
Тож рятувати тварин почав весь Миколаїв.
Був великий відгук від містян, люди приносили нам корм,
і ми цим кормом годували тварин.
Коли люди стали від'їжджати з Миколаєва, виїхало понад 250 тисяч людей.
Нам почали привозити, приносити домашніх тварин.
Це були і черепахи, і ящірки, і великі папуги, і маленькі папуги, і рибки.
Приходить дитина, каже:  "Будь ласка, у мене кролик, заберіть.
Як ми приїдемо - ми кролика заберемо".
І плаче. Ну, добре, давайте, брали того кролика.
Брали шиншил, дуже багато різних тварин.
Загалом Миколаївський зоопарк прийняв від містян, що виїжджали,
понад пів тисячі тварин. І лише за трьома десятками повернулися господарі,
більшість колись домашніх улюбленців й досі залишаються в зоопарку.
Це папуги. Ось папуги Жако у нас зараз сидять. Це папуги Фішера.
Також люди принесли, виїжджали. Ще було у нас багато таких тварин:
кролі, шиншили були, морські свинки.
Ми вже багато їх віддали на відділи, бо вони пройшли карантин у нас
і пішли по відділах. По здоров'ю вони більш-менш всі були здорові,
хворих якихось не було тварин, всі більш-менш в нормальному стані.
Ще чотири поні привезли з-під обстрілів українські військові.
Нині поні ситі, доглянуті і залюбки позують на камеру.
Були поні, вони в дуже нормальному стані, можна так сказати.
Ми їх прищепили, обробили, подивилися їх, клінічний огляд зробили.
Зараз вони в нормальному стані, вони вже в вольєрах, годуються, гуляють.
Проте рік тому на зоопарк чекали нові й нові випробування.
Навесні тварини, як і весь Миколаїв, залишилися без централізованого водопостачання.
Для зоопарку, у якому живе близько 4 тисяч тварин,
це могло обернутися катастрофою.
Нам воду привозили з Одеси, з Кропивницького.
Дуже допомагав наш водоканал, який кожен день привозив бочки з водою,
тому що в день 10 кубів води для зоопарку треба.
Це водойми, це басейни, це акваріум.
Треба ж тварини не тільки поїти, а й мити.
Ми дуже вдячні всім волонтерам, які привозили воду до зоопарку,
а ми бочками, відрами, як під час Другої світової війни,
розвозили по нашій території, близько 20 гектарів, і поїли цих тварин.
Питання з водою вирішили, коли вирили дві свердловини на території зоопарку.
Утім, на цьому випробування не завершилися.
Від масованих обстрілів РФ в Україні почалися блекаути.
А над тваринами знову нависла загроза загибелі.
Дуже тривожно було, коли одну добу, другу в зоопарку не було світла.
А для нас світло - це життя. Акваріуми, якщо там відключити компресори,
то риба вся загине. У слонів ворота працюють на електриці.
Якщо немає електрики, то ці ворота не відкриєш, не закриєш.
Нам дуже-дуже допомогли теж волонтери.
З празького зоопарку ми отримали безплатно в формі донату
потужний дизельний генератор на 80 кВт.
Попри війну, обстріли, блекаути тварини продовжували жити…
і розмножувалися.
8 березня, в самі тривожні часи, в нас народився далекосхідний леопард.
Їх було чотири у світі народжено, один - у нас.
Це дуже рідкісна кішка. А так, боже, мабуть, понад сто голів різних тварин
за цей час народилося у зоопарку.
І птахи, і ссавці, в тому числі й примати, і копитні тварини.
Вони не знають, що йде війна.
Миколаївський зоопарк зміг вижити завдяки допомозі небайдужих людей
не лише з України, а й усього світу.
Рік тому Віталій Топчій запустив міжнародну акцію
"Придбай онлайн-квиток у зоопарк".
Тоді вдалося зібрати десятки мільйонів гривень.
На ці гроші зоопарк живе й донині.